a steady job with a good salary and a
lucrative bonus that's the promise that
tempts many Indonesian men to leave
their homes and help to see but what
they get is this footage released by the
Indonesian seafarers movement shows crew
members sleeping on the floor in the
cargo hold
looking malnourished and exhausted one
of them is rahmatullah he says he was
tricked by an Indonesian recruiting
agency trafficked to Somalia and forced
to spend nine brutal months aboard a
Chinese fishing boat Manning nets and
packing fish for 18 hours a day when we
didn't catch enough fish or squid we
were beaten by the captain we were
beaten a lot I'm still traumatized by it
on board the crew claimed they were
given a choice between going hungry and
eating spoiled fish and they didn't even
have clean water on the vacation we were
given fish we could tell by the smell
that the fish was already bad after
smelling it we couldn't eat it on a
daily basis all we got was cabbage and
rice with a little salt and we drank
condensation water that we collected
from the air conditioner rahmatullah and
his crewmates are now back home and
they've taken photos and videos to
document their experience
experts say the fishing industry is
riddled with forced labor and it
predominantly targets poor workers from
Southeast Asian once on board there's no
way out for the men and they often
mercilessly exploited rahmatullah and
his crewmates say they owed thousands of
dollars in unpaid wages
fire I worked faraway for my family so
they could be proud of me when I
returned home but the reality was
different when I asked the recruitment
company for our rights
they said you're a stupid idiot we just
wanted to ask for our rights after
working for seven months numerous NGOs
both local and international have rung
the alarm about the slave-like
conditions that seem to be commonplace
on fishing vessels across the globe but
it hasn't stopped men like these from
falling into the hands of traffickers in
an Aegis Ministry of Manpower is among
other things tasked with a protection of
its workers abroad the department head
acknowledges the problem but says it's
difficult to monitor labor conditions at
sea
do we need to study first whether the
information about the abused seafarers
is true or not we must rely on data and
facts so we can enforce actions lawfully
corridor unda Munda but as rahmatullah
and his former crewmates know data and
facts are difficult to obtain when
you're at sea with no one watching now
the University of Western Australia and
the sea around us research initiative
have investigated forced labor on the
high seas a little earlier I spoke to
senior researcher David tickler about
what they found
we found a vicious cycle between
overfishing and forced labour basically
slave labour subsidizes uh no economic
fishing activity and the resulting
overfishing then destroys profitability
and further incentivizes the use of
forced labour boats have to fish harder
to fill their nets and this is because
the global catch has been declining
steadily since the mid 90s the constants
we squeeze on profitability means that
seek more and more desperate measures to
cut their costs cruel often the largest
and easiest cost to cut to cut and so
slave labor is the tactic of choice for
unscrupulous operators we found almost
40 percent of the global catch came from
fleets that were a high risk of modern
slavery now it's not as if the media
hasn't reported on this The Associated
Press even want to Pulitzer Prize for
its reporting on slavery in the seafood
industry a few years ago and their
investigation resulted in the release of
a couple thousand workers from Myanmar
yet it doesn't look like much has
changed why because the Associated Press
reporting this issue is now getting more
attention than ever before and there has
been changed on the ground in 2015 the
EU issued a yellow card against Thailand
basically notifying it that if it didn't
do something about illegal fishing and
Sabre in its fisheries the EU would cut
off access to the European market for
seafood Thailand's response was to
completely redo its domestic fisheries
legislation including putting in place
sanctions for forced labor and at the
end of last year they were formally
recognizing undocumented workers from
places like Myanmar and giving them full
legal protections however it's still a
major issue
partly because enforcing these
regulations is incredibly difficult
especially when the offense is often
taking place out at sea there's also
ongoing demand for cheap seafood which
we're all responsible for and of course
this puts pressure on costs and there's
evidence that there's complicity still
between officials and the people
trafficking people into forced labor and
Fisheries which makes it very hard to
undermine so which undermines rather the
attempts to address this problem that
was david tickler a senior researcher
and lead author of a report on modern
slavery at sea